is trying to recover from the loss of
her parents
they both died of covet 19.
it is very hard i've been left alone my
siblings live in different places first
my mother died and then my father
i don't know what to feel anymore about
this terrible disease
argentina has reached the grim milestone
of 100 000 covert 19 deaths
it's one of the hardest hit nations in
the region even though daily average
case numbers have fallen since the peak
last month
so far fewer than 10 percent of the
country's 45 million people
have been inoculated with two doses but
an increase in vaccination in the past
month
is raising hope the country will be able
to control the pandemic
every life that is gone is a great
regret for me to those who have lost a
loved one
you'll always find solidarity love and
regret for what you have had to live
but i can guarantee you that the exit
door is near
we're not going to stop in these months
vaccinating each and every argentine man
and woman but it's also the associated
economic crisis
that has people here extremely concerned
poverty rates and unemployment have
soared
amid covet and the country's battle with
chronic long-term economic difficulties
it's not just the pandemic drowning us
in this country there's also the huge
economic crisis
many relatives call us crying not only
because of the death
but because they don't have the money to
bury their loved ones we have to act as
psychologists to these people
argentina was one of the first countries
in the region to impose strict lockdown
measures to prevent the spread of covet
19
and thanks to that experts say the
health care system survived
earlier this year the government
reimposed some of those strict
lockdown measures in an attempt to
control the virus variants
many of those restrictions have now been
suspended but the government maintains
controls at the border
and at the airport were only a few
flights from overseas
are allowed to land every day teresa
buenos aires